well wynn las vegas has postponed the
inevitable but changes may cause
layoffs now right after the holidays it
comes after back and forth with the
culinary union
orco mana is just outside the wind
tonight to give us more detail
details about what this could mean for
workers there orco
well denise the wind says the local
culinary union is requiring them
to move full-time employees back to
40-hour work weeks
but the resort warns that that will
force them to make major layoffs
eight news now obtained a copy of this
letter that was sent from wynn resorts
to its staff monday it says since
reopening the win and encore in june
the company has tried to keep as many
people employed as possible
even if it meant each individual worked
fewer hours the letter goes on to state
that the culinary union believed this
was the right approach
up until about a month ago when resort
says last week the union required them
to schedule full-time employees for 40
hours a week
to which the company responded saying it
would force them to lay off many workers
the union has since agreed to delay the
schedule changes until
after the holidays on january 11. the
union says this is all part of their
negotiations in a statement the culinary
union says when resorts took advantage
of the union's flexibility during the
pandemic
and is urging wynn resorts to agree to
protect their employees
and extend health care benefits for
their workers just like mgm
caesars and other casinos have already
done
now when resort says that while it would
like to keep things the way they are now
they have to listen to the union's
demands
they are currently working on making
schedule changes which again
go into effect on january 11th reporting
live near the wind tonight orco mana 8
news now